I've had phrase ivr seek in the staffing
thank you very much you need good
evening everybody it's good to be here
for the first time in about nine months
I've had a very short break away and
went to Scotland to the highlands near
aviemore to stay with some friends and
what we were there we went to Brody
castle the home of the Brody clan so if
there's anyone here who's from the Brody
clan then you know what I'm talking
about and they had the motto unite
nothing to do with the Union I hasten to
add and while we were in showing round
the castle we were shown this dinner
service which had many hundreds of
pieces all hand-painted in China and all
of them had the crest the motto on there
unites except two pieces at which there
had misspellings instead of unite they
had untie only two letters out of place
but crucially changed the meaning of
that motto a fine line between the
positive and the negative between unity
and disunity or unity is a vital part of
the Christian faith as we can read in a
number of Bible passages we read in
Psalm 133 from the Old Testament how
good and pleasant it is when God's
people live together in unity and in the
New Testament the Apostle Paul writes to
the people of Ephesus make every effort
to keep the unity of the Spirit through
the bond of peace I'd like to encourage
you all as counsel and community and all
that you do to support the community of
which we live to live and work together
in unity which doesn't mean uniformity
to live together in unity with a
determination to work together for peace
a peace in our community a peace that
the world at large is struggling to know
so let us pray
there's will a prayer at force and
Georgia's day Heavenly Father give us
the bravery us and George to stand up
for what we believe give us the strength
to overcome the difficulties in our
lives and in the world and where we see
people in distress
give us the compassion to help them and
a prayer of thanksgiving and for this
meeting this evening Lord God you have
taught us that we are called to live
together we thank you for the community
of which we are a part for all who share
in its many activities and for all who
serve its various interests we pray for
all who are members of this council and
represent the people in this district of
Rockford through this meeting and as
they work together we pray that this
council may be given sacrificial courage
in order to enrich the welfare of all
whom they serve through Jesus Christ our
Lord amen
I do hope you have a good positive and
unifying meeting this evening one which
is carried out with great peace I'm
sorry I can't stay to be with you but as
I go depart to my next meeting I'll hold
you all in my prayers and look forward
to seeing you next month thank you very
much indeed
thank you
[Music]
apologies good evening
counselors and members of the public we
have a very very full agenda this
evening can we please keep to the main
points of each item if you find you are
too hot
yes please take your jacket off right
first item is apologies for accents
I had counselor mrs. butcher and
counselor Lucy Julie Gooden and also
counselor Terry khatma and I believe
counselor Mike step so I wanted to just
say a few words
yes thank you chairman and as many of
the members wore hello here I've ever
here this evening
Terry was taken into hospital and the
early hours of Monday morning I spoke to
him yesterday and he was a big robbery
yesterday but I did get an email from
him this evening it's actually timed at
1648 at 10:00 to 5:00 and he's very
simply says Mike just left Hospital
absolutely dead on my feet with dietary
so I think he's on the mend but I'm sure
we'd all we be happy to send our best
wishes to him and hope he gets well soon
Thank You campus exploration counselor
Mason said I'm very good
that's amazing this evening evening hope
it will calm itself down chairman I'd
like to echo the thoughts substantial
step day by saying of course we wish
Terry a speedy recovery and I've already
wished him luck in the council council
elections so I wish him luck against the
company's well thank you Thank You
council information
number two minutes of the extraordinary
meal chip meeting held on the 14th of
February and the meeting Hilden 21st of
February I believe agreed members number
three to receive declarations of
interest counseling which is June lovely
ok and non-pecuniary interest in item
six and item 17 as committee member
factory
Thank You Chancellor Lee count to Jorge
I renew a non-pecuniary interest in item
six and 17 the century Thank You
counselor counselor dear lord please
madam chairman declare a non-pecuniary
in items six and seven as a member of
the secretary 1617 as a member of
secretary Housing Committee Thank You
Catherine
chairman are there any other interests
at all chairman rummy and just to
clarify on these and members interests
advice was given prior to this meeting
to the members about their nan between
the interests and and because of their
involvement with sanitary housing you
may give rise to sexual advice therefore
they've been advised that they may want
to wish and may want to leave the
chamber prior to their debate and will
not be taking home alone thank you very
very much another number for
announcements from Chairman leader or
head of paid services I think I believe
councilors step two oh you're going to
do a report as evening notes
underscoring we're a man now exactly not
yet number five public questions our
notice there are none number six
presentation of the petition pursuant to
procedure of rule 11 and John boss stop
will say a few words first
you
you
cancelled your Mason do you want to ever
say something
Sarah nodding I was indicating right I'd
like to speak when the magician is
represented
that's that sign counselor John
pursuant to the council procedure rules
a petitions been received for mr.
Richard lambourn containing 1646
signatures which means it's reached the
threshold 1500 at which it would evoke
be debated at full council in accordance
with procedural rules the petition
organiser or a person acting on their
behalf will be allowed a maximum of five
minutes to present the petition members
will be allowed a maximum of 15 minutes
for debate debate should be directed to
action required by the petition the
authority is in the period a perder
which does not preclude the continuation
of council business but means that
members are not to refer to the County
Council election campaign the petition
relates to matters that fall within the
District Council's remit following
debates the council will decide how to
respond to the petition by either taking
the action requested in the petition not
taking the action requested for reasons
put forward in the debates or
commissioning further investigation into
the matter
thank you chairman thank you thank you
can I sorry can I please invite counsel
can I see the right count for June army
to do statement Thank You chairman
making this statement is portfolio
holder for community and then I will
leave the chamber the offer from
sanctuary Housing Association to enable
Francisco T Lodge to provide temporary
accommodation within the district for
our homeless families is a tremendous
opportunity for the council we have so
far managed to meet the statutory duty
placed on the council to provide
emergency temporary accommodation but at
an ever-increasing cost and by using B&B
accommodation located outside of the
district having the opportunity to use
Francis Cote Lodge will therefore enable
us to more effectively made local needs
as people who find themselves homeless
can stay in the district where they will
have local connections for example close
to home work schools and local support
networks I am sure we would all agree
that placing residents in BMB
accommodation outside of our district
should be an action of last resort in
addition at a time of increasing demand
for homeless services francisco t lodge
also provides a significant opportunity
to assist the council in reducing the
considerable cost of being the
accommodation a saving for both the
council and the council taxpayer our
agreed budget already includes saving
from the use of francisco t lodge there
are no legal restrictions on francisco t
lodge which prevent the council from
using the property as temporary
accommodation for homeless families and
there is no planning change of use this
is a residential property in a
residential area and it will continue as
such there is no doubt that seeking to
provide suitable temporary accommodation
for our homeless families poses a
significant challenge for us all and the
use of francisco t lodge should be seen
as a not
to natee to not only meet our statutory
duties and minimize costs but most
importantly to help local residents with
a critical housing need stay connected
to the district we are looking at other
options of course but in addition to
Francis Cote Lodge not an alternative
which reflects the scale of the
challenges we are facing finally if the
council did pass up this opportunity
there can be no guarantees of the
alternative arrangements that Secretary
Housing Association might put in place
there are no restrictions on the
residential occupation of the building
and it might for example be offered to
other councils to exist there homeless
problems
thank you Tim Thank You councillor
lovely you're about to leave now
you
I understand mrs. Michel Newton is going
to present the report in sort of Richard
lamborne would you like to come forward
please
Michelle me sure you will have five
minutes when we get to floor let you
know Dominic left okay okay thank you
and our petition was raised against the
change of views for France's coffee
knowledge from sheltered accommodation
for the over fifty five to ten free
accommodation for the homeless and the
removal of the over fifty five
requirement for the planet for a flat
the petition exceeded the number of
signatures required to force this debate
due to the significant objection of
local residents our first concern is the
impact on the elderly residents being
forced to move from their homes some
residents have lived upon squatting odd
for a considerable time and have been
caused worry and anxiety which is
detrimental to their health moving to
different accommodation is not only
stressful it may require a change of GP
pharmacy and other care providers in
fact Age Concern postponed its website
moving an older person from a home where
they have been resident for a long time
is likely to have a serious impact on
their way of life they also state that
residents have a reasonable expectation
that their home would be their home for
life losing them may actually be a
breach of their human rights
Emma Keegan managing director of century
housing stated that residents will be
given a maximum of three offers of
alternative accommodation after which
they will be evicted we would like the
council to consider the lack of
compassion to the elderly residents we
object a little close use of this
facility as temporary accommodation to
the homeless the building is already
detrimental to the area due to its
dilapidated condition
sanctuary housing has a poor reputation
for maintenance and it is evident they
cannot be trusted to maintain and
monitor this facility at an acceptable
and safe level
this was illustrated by the recent fire
spark alton Hockley we're only 5 out of
48 smoke alarms activation the intention
is to fastly overpopulate buildings
although we relate to believe the
occupants will be predominantly rain
families with children in local schools
it is now apparent that there will be a
combination of single people couples and
families most of whom are expected to be
vulnerable and unemployed the statistics
provided by work for housing ending
October 16 state that only 2% of
homeless applications were from your
award
and after 452 applications 45 were from
raylene the response to my request for
information under the Freedom of
Information Act confirms that as of 31
January 17 9 household from a libras
bed-and-breakfast accommodations
provided by the council the residence
would consider it fairer to distribute
temporary accommodation across the
district into smaller units which we
understand from a former housing officer
was the preferred policy prior to this
proposal the impact of such a large
population concentrated in a small area
of Raley which is not currently affected
by homelessness with unfair the
continuous lack of information and the
secrecy has contributed to our concern
together with the absence of response
from the reason loss in June Romney this
is a strong opposition that deserves to
be heard the over 65 age restriction for
the current trial flats has been removed
but there is no guarantee that they will
not also be used as temporary
accommodation in the future
Emma Kagan states that there will be a
nominations agreement or similarly good
agreement between watch the District
Council and sanctuary housing will the
content of this agreement be available
on the council's website
and will the terms be subject to review
by this chamber the concern is that
private Kakinada will become rundown and
undesirable stigmatizing the entire area
surely it will be preferable to have 2
or 3 units available the temporary
accommodation within buildings with
permanent secretary residents not only
with this reduce the density of
population from this courtyard
and potential associated problems that
would be much better for the temporary
residence if they would not be marked
out the timeliness it's been advised
that there would only be award and
provided in the daytime and on weekdays
and we consider this to be an added
clarity the cost of housing people in
bed-and-breakfast accommodation or homes
outside the area has constantly been
mentioned of the reasons of the change
of use how the cost comparison studies
been undertaken and exactly how much
money will be saved and can that be
presented to the council and not exempt
we are aware that the council and
offices in South Street which could be
converted to residential use we don't
want another a--casey house
we note that Essex County Council is
redeveloping rotary school there are
revised proposals of all would hold the
police station in Watford is being
developed and land a cage filled class
is being sold all of these a possible
alternative
in conclusion we ask that you support
our petition or at least you defer any
vote until you receive a free costed
project plan for the next five years and
the nomination agreement approved life
for Council would fix performance
criteria and end date we would like to
thank everyone for their time and
sincerely hope that as our elected
councillors you will consider the
strength of feeling in the community and
take the time to reconsider this plan
and be prepared to the comparative
solutions including whether sanctuary or
the best part of the such a facility
thank you
[Applause]
we have 15 minutes in which to debate on
this item
can we please 60 points of the items and
I've got a few names to begin with
counselor John Mason thank you Kevin
genin is it do you think a bigger idea
to turn it on extra for the receipt
sermon whilst I I agree with many of the
concerns and complaints made by
residents including the way that
existing elderly tenants seems have been
treated I'm afraid I can't agree with
the conclusive request of the
petitioners I'm going to explain why
nationally fifty percent of homeless
families are women with two children I
don't want them or any other composition
of homeless families do we sent to B&B
in Southend or even worse in Kent pit C
or Harlow their lives are here and with
90 families or more from our district
needing temporary accommodation this was
undoubtedly the quickest means of
housing them in the district much nearer
then to their previous homes families
and schools we will need as a district
as a council more temporary
accommodation in our district and I am
sure that there will be in other parts
of the districts similar facilities not
just Raley I'm not happy about the way
the council and sanctuary have carried
out this project and that is something
the residents have put and there are
many many questions I've got listed here
that I would like to ask but we don't
have the time this evening chairman as
you put to ask all of these questions
and enter into the bate longer than 15
minutes so I propose I move that review
committee carry out an investigation and
put recommendations back to full council
that's German fits with the third option
which is Commission further work thank
you Jim
I was a second-rank trim thank you
counting on Mason thanks Thank You
councillor Bob me aunty as a ward
councillor I've had a serious look at
situation and the background of it
there's a lot misinformation on the
internet about this in considering the
petition the background is that by 2015
Francis Cote Lodge was half-empty
and there were no over 55 queuing up to
get in there it's because this is a high
on home ownership area and people prefer
disabled facility grants and don't want
to move into single room bed seats in an
old-fashioned block now this was against
a demand for emergency homeless
accommodation mainly by local families
and a lack of affordable accommodation
in the area and they just using bed and
breakfast now sanctuary housing took the
decision in light the fact that I
understand it that they were going to
refurbish Francis Scott Key Lodge to
move and we're going to move the
residents out that was a situation I was
elected I didn't know about the homeless
situation and then we're going to use
the block as a temporary accommodation
the council did not plan or instigate
the change of use and any of them
there's never been a caveat that you
have to be over 55 to living Frances
Country Lodge the truth is there are no
elderly people queuing to get in there
and there has not been any complaints
from the existing residents about moving
out but most of them are actually very
pleased what they've got
I've understand there's only one person
still live in the year's time I suspect
anyone walking along
Clarence Road would just see Francis
Scotty lodger refurbished block and
nothing more
now the poorly drafted in my view ray
Lee action group leaflet which has got
some misleading features about it does
not mention the vital fact if the
council complies with a petition then we
will not have nomination rights and then
sanctuary could move anyone in there
from anywhere so for that reason we
should not vote to adopt the petition
it's not within the council authority
they're happening now the costs of
France's cautery Lodge have we've been
asked about it is zero because we do not
collect the rents we do not own the
building so as a zero cost virtually to
the council and the council cannot sell
off rooms in transit Scotty lots of
other authorities as implied on the
internet and Facebook site Brady Action
Group field because we don't own it so
the count in my view then should not
adopt the recommendations in this
petition although there is an issue to
do with calling in to review which I
agree with John Mason Thank You counsel
councilman counter mr. Shaw please Thank
You chairman do I agree with the way
sanctuary of dealt with this no I don't
do I support the petition absolutely not
over 1600 people have signed this
petition and it's clearly been misled I
personally have not had many calls on
the subject but those that have
contacted me or stopped me in the street
are stunned when I tell them what they
have signed and that is to not look
after our residents within our district
I also find it bizarre as to how many
children have signed this petition
clearly this is a number to go in
chairman thank you can throw count to
the phylactery yes Thank You chairman
yes I'll be brief
I don't know whether any children did
sign this petition
well maybe it you've gotta get to 1,500
odd even if it's only a thousand adults
we've signed it then if a thousand
adults you know thousand measurements in
a district signed a petition but I think
they certainly serve 15 minutes
discussing in fact I think 15 minutes is
rather than the short side if it's
important enough for residents to to
feel like this I could talk with lots
but I won't I'll just say I support
councilor Mason's proposal to go to you
to review committee thank you Thank You
council ACK
counselor mrs. Christine Mason please
you
[Music]
you
you
you
you
Thank You counsel mr. Christie Mason
counselor Michael Hoyt please Thank You
chairman I'm speaking to the motion
which will be cigar seconded and all
very very people of race really the
place I was going to raise I agree with
many of the places in the petition I
don't agree with all of it as I've said
I homeless is a real problem in the area
and I think we really need to deal with
it I am very unhappy with how sentry
operate of the experienced the moving
elderly people outs of tinder house in
whole bridge and they refer to the
process as decanting which I don't find
appropriate in any way at all and I
think they've referred to that in this
case as well and I feel their lack of
communication in this is very poor I
also think that we as a council have not
thought as counselors even haven't been
very well informed of what's been going
on we were aware of it we haven't been
as fully briefed on this as we should
have been throughout the process which
is why I believe it should come back to
reviewing which is one second in the
motion I would also add to councilor
choro I'm not sure how many children
have signs petition why can't a child
sign a petition their residents still
that's because I haven't voted for any
of us doesn't mean they're not residence
thank you cancer microwave counters a
despairing please
thank you very much Aaron I've listened
to the comments made by some of my
colleagues and and by and large
completely agree with a lot of what is
being said however I do have some
concerns with regards to the whole
situation I think we we were all pretty
concerned about sanctuary and the way
they operate I don't think there's any
doubt about some of those issues my
concern is what can we actually do with
them and in that basis I listen to what
counts the Mason and councillor who have
said and their proposal but I couldn't
support that I my concern is and I would
say that I will propose that we take no
further action on this occasion and do
not comply with the requests and my
reasons for this I support the statement
that councillor lammle made and the
issue she raised there I think that
nobody has reiterated that council has a
statutory requirement to home our
homeless people that several
presentations that I have received as
has fellow councillors I don't think
there's any doubt that there are
substantial savings to be made if we use
Francis kotti lodge we can argue about
figures but I'm quite comfortable that
there are considerable savings Francis
kotti logic is not the only area of
potential use for the homeless and last
but not least charity in my view begins
at home we need to look after our own
homeless people and I have great
concerns that if we don't take this
opportunity and utilise Francis cozy
Lodge sanctuary will not wait for us to
go to review committees they will do
whatever they want to do and before we
can go back and do whatever they will
have moved in a homeless people from
other boroughs and I am very concerned
but if we don't take the opportunity
somebody else will thank you David
we've got four minutes left and I've got
three more speakers as accounts of some
City
so
Bingley summed up the the issues that
we've got we have a problem it's right
here it's right now there's a number of
points been made about how this issue is
developed but I do believe that the fact
that people want are wanting to live in
their own homes through disabled
facilities grants the fact that Francis
kotti is of substandard and I do believe
that was admitted by the petitioner and
of course part of any refurbishment
however it happens involves people
moving out so if you were the fact that
the problem is immediate and that we're
looking at serving our residents then I
do believe that we need to move forward
on this straight away and not take any
further action on the petition if
something else were to be examined later
on by review committee that that's a
matter for review committee but I don't
believe that it is right now to delay
anything any further with this issue
thinking Catholic gravely thank you
madam chairman if I have been listening
to the debate this evening I understand
from planning law there is there is no
change of use in relation to Plan C
Scotty Lodge and but obviously there is
an aspect which the community views that
there is a change of youth we do have
responsibilities to house homeless
people that surf all in our area and it
is obviously right for us to try their
best to to find appropriate
accommodation for them
I do have concerns about how sanctuary
as behaved in relation to this this
matter although we have limited ability
to control what they what they may or
may not do however I am going to support
the motion because I think it is
appropriate that the review committee to
it should should look at this and also
other aspects of homelessness in our in
our district thank you
you
thanks Jared and really I just wanted to
second pencil is very emotion there and
the phrase that springs to my mind
sorry sorry yes there is a motion as
well sorry cancer so you can't do that
if I'm just going to I was going to say
was my biggest concern is if we don't
use it we're going to lose it and we'll
have some other counsel putting their
homeless in their place Thank You
councillor cata mr. Hyde please and yeah
I will be supporting the motion and we
do have a big problem of homelessness in
Rockford I mean I have been to surfing
so I know what it's well I've seen
firsthand what it's like to be homeless
I mean sanctuary I can only go by
tyndale house in whole bridge they are
ruthless and the only word I can
describe forum and so I will be
supporting the motion
thank you can see me okay members
and I'm driving to our members because
[Music]
there is a member there is a motion on
the floor by council mr. Mason seconded
by Councillor mr. hoy and I understand
you want to recall his vote Thank You
chairman
so the motion is that the review
committee carry out an investigation
you can sit counter the most recent
review committee carried out an
investigation and put recommendations
back to full council Thank You
[Music]
councillor black councillor Burton
councillor Carter counselor mrs. Kassar
councillor Kufa count for the Dre
councillor ft councillor heed councillor
Griffin councillor Hazelwood councillor
hook play councillor Diane hoy counselor
Michael boy counselor mrs. Hughes
counsel you are knit okay counselor
Lucas Gill councillor Christine Mason
counter Elliot Mason's counselor John
Mason councillor Mirek counsel Emil
counselor Mountain Council a Newport
councillor oten or counselor mrs. Rowe
counselor mrs. Shaw councillor Smith
counter the sparing Cal sort of Stanley
count for the step though
councilor web counselor mrs. Weston
again councillor William counselor
Wilson
remembers the motion is carried
for me asked the other counselors oh I'm
not sure see the residents are going to
carry on staying here after that I can
be your most welcome to to continue down
if you wish or if you wish to leave by
all means
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
okay Cass counselors can we carry yes
Mike yes mr. secretary could I just ask
when the review committee is likely to
meet and be reported back to this
council is that a question for the
meeting this evening if I can try and
adjust I mean I'm only the current
chairman so honestly I think we would
put in two plans that it would be as
soon as possible it would be probably an
extra an extra meeting of the review
committee to discuss this because I
imagine it'd be quite a contentious and
lengthy meeting I'd have to seek the
support of committee members discuss it
with allgauer's before we could actually
witness that isn't possible tonight it's
very difficult to given an exact answer
but rest assured either myself or
whoever is chair of the review committee
in the next fiscal year I'm sure we'll
look to to have this debated as soon as
possible thanks thank you thank you
can't do very much council motions sorry
counsel John Mason please Tim I met
seemed an open question so I felt
obliged or at least empowered to learn
to respond as well and I've welcomed a
review of committee as soon as possible
as counsel Burton says but actually I'd
welcome um before annual council so
there's a challenge to the members of
review committee meet and decide on this
matter and party factory of the next
school council having listened carefully
to what other members are concerned
about that would be the best way of
dealing with it Thank You Jenna
Thank You counselors you're making
Justin responds that yep that's
absolutely fine I'll take that with poor
gals and members of the committee
tomorrow with the view to have setting a
date
okay thanks thank you very much item
seven members member Christians on
notice counselor black please thank you
my first question is as of a tenth of
April this year how many planning
enforcement cases were outstanding
councillor Ward are you going to answer
the question police thank you Thank You
Mel insurance to date there are 265
cases outstanding as of the 10th of
April 2017 of these 235 cases of
currently being investigated and 30 are
being monitored following formal action
thank you
Thank You counsel counsel black - yes a
lot eventually to that um do you believe
that we have enough resources in terms
of money and in terms of start to reduce
that number to a more reasonable level
cancer or disease
with regard to to staff and finances I
believe this is something that we are
constantly been looking at we understand
there are needs and those are things
that we are considering constantly Thank
You counsel counsel back please thank
you um as of the 10th of April this year
how many full-time planning officers
were directly employed by the council
and not on sick leave prevent to leave
on holiday councillor Ward thank you
madam chair as of the 10th of April
there were three of six development
management planning officers directly
employed by the council in the office
thank you can't afford counsel of
Blackford question please question is
how many cases are you aware of it for
2017 this year we're a notice of
decision indicates the wrong information
I incorrectly states that the
application has been passed and the
actual decision was to diffuse or vice
versa counter in Ward please thank again
there is only one case where a notice of
decision indicated incorrect information
Thank You councillor Ward thank you
thank you can select item 8 speeches
from the last council meeting there is
none item 9 to note the minutes of the
executive and committee meetings held
between the period sent for February to
the 17th of April as listed noted
members rated item 10 to consider any
report from the executive and committees
to council Council a black I believe
you're going to please yep Thank You
chairman and as you'll see there
apologizes
agenda item 10 1 which is the review
committee on the review of the
Constitution the review committee of
project team was created consisting of
cross party members to undertake an
overdue review of the council's
Constitution at first glance the report
which has been circulated to members
probably appears rather lengthy it's 77
pages however this is merely so that
members can clearly see the proposed
changes in review how these changes will
appear once the Constitution has been
amended as the report informing members
the proposed changes have been discussed
at link for the monitoring officer and
agreed upon between all members the
purpose of this review was to update and
include natural changes that required
alterations such as changes in personnel
etc it was also to ensure the language
used was clearer and more up-to-date
information and guidance within was
consistent in correct and that overall
it became slightly less challenging to
follow the project team along with the
monitoring officer and the overview and
scrutiny officer we're all aware from
the outset that this could be a lengthy
project to work on and all agree that
working toward specific milestones with
a view to completing this project in
phases would be the best way forward and
that it was highly likely that these
milestones would have to be flexible as
you can see the project team have almost
completed parts 1 & 2 part 3 will be
completed as soon as possible going into
the next musical year many members have
any questions or queries regarding this
ongoing project can i please ask them to
refer these so I myself or probably more
appropriately monitoring officer thank
you
otherwise the recommendation of on page
10 1 both together - it is supposed that
council resolves item 1 item 2 of that
as it agreed members thank you and
counselor person annual report of the
review committee please yes
thank you chairman members have also had
a chance to review the review committees
annual report which has been circulated
the content of this report is pretty
self-explanatory and provides members
and non-members with fairly detailed
information on the work the review
committee has undertaken during the past
12 months which I hope will be of
interest to all on a personal note as
I've turned my large review committee
meeting well I thought we had of the
current really several year I'll take
this opportunity anyway to thank members
devote their time and patience and in
particular their support throughout the
last 12 months I thoroughly enjoyed
chairing this committee and it's been a
privilege to get to know so many members
from other parties whom I may not have
had the chance to get to know otherwise
in particular I'd like to thank my vice
chairman councillor Hazelwood
for his assistance and encouragement
I've really enjoyed working alongside a
crime and also to both poor girls and
Michelle Powell for their guidance and
help which has been which has been very
much appreciated not to mention
invaluable at times thank you Thank You
council Burton any questions members it
is on page 10 - it is proposed account
to resolve to receive the an report as
attached appendix - is that agreed
members number 11 report on urgency
visions there are none number 12 report
for the leader on the work of the exec I
understand count to Mike stich I was
going to this experiment pin and I'm
sure you've all spotted that up I'm not
counselor cut more thorough and my
commiserations to Carol Burt and I know
it's like when the chamber gets an angel
development on and right here go this is
the fifth an ordinary council meeting of
2016-17 this appeal rule year since the
annual council I would like to welcome
all members since a meeting the 21st of
February the executive has met once
during which consideration was given to
the quarter 3 2016-17 financial
management reports it was agreed that
4500 pound to be drawn down from the
play spaces to 1718 capital budget for
the purpose of match funding and that
the authority be delegated to the
assistant director environmental
services in consultation with the
portfolio holder for environment
to approve of grant award the 45,000
pound from quarry environmental trust
and consequently execute the project
other matters that my colleagues and I
have on the executive have been dealing
with include adopting a new model
license conditions and guidance for dog
boarding and home dog boarding licensing
agreeing to increase the authority fare
tariffs for Hackney carriages agree in
the southeast Essex strategic parking
planning beg pardon men a random of
understanding 2017 as always I will be
happy to take any questions for members
in respect to the work of the executive
and I'm sure my executive colleagues
will be happy to contribute the clear
project Thank You councillor Mike
Spencer any Christians council black
please ask questions the self Essex
strategic planning Memorandum of
Understanding 2017 could one of the
portfolio holders please clarify the
members what that involves and what the
implications are please cap capsule
board thank you madam chairman the
Memorandum of Understanding is basically
the concept of the various councils and
boroughs working together in a way in
which they actually understand
fundamentally what they're trying to do
so it's a very strategic level I think
my ad who was one of the main people who
was working with it would probably be
better explaining this in detail but at
the portfolio's older certainty
[Laughter]
chairman yes just to sort of clarify I'm
not sure how much detail if you want to
know but it sorry okay it basically sets
out the parameters and framework for the
planning authorities of South Essex to
work under the duty to cooperate to
understand how they deal with strategic
planning matters between the cross
boundary areas within South Essex so
that includes buzzard and ferret castle
point ruptured and Southend no more
questions
item 13 councillor John Mason please
thank you and I think this is calm down
now isn't it I obviously think it into
submission okay and you probably know
that the proper officer reports that
pursuant to council procedural rule 13
the following motion has been received
from councillors Jareth Mason me
counselor mrs. CN Mason my P ok Mason
this is TR fused GE Newport sa Wilson
ahe & CI black the motion reads this
council wishes to and agrees to invites
the local NHS organisations to undertake
presentations at a full council or a
special additional full council on the
proposed changes particularly to A&E
provisions and elective surgery location
and capacity no later than 14 days
before the closure of any public
consultation arranged by the NHS
notwithstanding the above pull Council
agrees to have a full debate at a full
council or a special additional full
council on the proposed changes no later
than 14 days before the closure of any
public consultation arranged by the NHS
and as you can tell chairman I must have
been frightened by a lawyer the moment I
put my pen to paper that statista motion
thank you emotionally the motion is
moved and so it needs to be moved
apparently if the motion is moved
counselor missus okay accounts of John
Mason you're going to move the motion
and counselor mrs. Mason's going to
second but yes Sharon please for the
sake of girl I so move
I didn't use those words bike so move
now thank you thank you right cancer
science miss Lee I must have admit to a
slight degree of ignorance at this point
but I don't know in all honesty how
frequently and how often the NHS go out
to consult on changes and my only
concern with this motion is that we
could be here every week having a debate
I don't know whether that is the case or
whether it's likely to be once or twice
a year but I think it is important to
have some knowledge in that area am i
ignorant doesn't allow me to make an
informed decision at this moment in time
Catherine mr. John Mason and on to that
and we went we were we were blessed in
certain respects at the NHS came to the
review committee I believe it was
November and during questioning she
normally doing review committee we asked
the then chief executive of South in
universal trust hospital when the
consultation would take place and the
consultation we revised would take place
after the county council elections but
in May so we can expect this
consultation in May however we now have
a general election that I don't know how
the NHS fits in with a general election
but for councillors Smith's eat
a suggestion for counselor Smith to
consider maybe gym counselors black
please yes I might disapprove emotions
obviously I was glad to support it this
isn't just a consultation on something
obscuring the NHS it's something pretty
fundamental regarding actions in
emergency and some other features I
think it's only right and proper that we
look after interest of our residents and
we we get a full presentation imma let
the V NHS know what we think about it
thank you Thank You Council at council
hook way please
thank you madam chairman my name is
anand emotion if i had the opportunity
to put it on it i I would would do now I
do support it and I hope my colleagues
do support this as well I think this is
this is a very well worded motion and
it's all about informing us as a
residence representatives and allowing
public debate so that people can
understand what's going on with our
local health service thank you Thank You
council Quay members is a it's been
moved and seconded
a two week oh sorry counselor hi Michael
hi please sorry I will be greater than
I've got a lot to it what I say I tools
at the review committee and I found the
presentation they're quite formative but
it it did show that there was a lot of
information that I still didn't know and
I think a debate at full council on this
matter would be very very useful for all
members
thank you Thank You counsel hi and how
do we all agree or do want to serve
hangs all agree all agree Thank You
members 14 pay policy statement to to
consider the report the management
managing director on a paid policy
statement for 2017-18
and Sean will presenters me chairman I
just actually have one particular
comment a minor correction from well
actually not perhaps not so so minor if
I can draw members attention to
paragraph three point five of the
the report the mention there is of the
Hutton review of fair pay and it
mentions mean average earnings that
should be median average earnings so
that's a correction and and remembers
that follows through to the the pay
policy into paragraph 7.1 where that the
same correction and needs to be needs to
be applied thank you thank you any
questions it is proposed that counts are
resolved at the pay policy statement for
2017-18 be adopted without minor
amendment is that agreed members item 15
purpose-built doctor surgery
successfully national business rates
appeals and met pet weekly on simoleons
orange mr. Menon Thank You Jay
meaning even everyone and if I break
into a cough I could apologize so and
okay I'll keep this brief
unfortunately and for there's been a a
legal case that was a test case carried
out in 2016-17 so the year just gone
where are purpose-built doctors
surgeries were able to appeal their
rateable value for business rates this
was successful and four of the
purpose-built doctor surgeries we have
in the region or in the district RM have
been successful in their appeals as well
and that has meant that we have to pay
back or refund about four hundred and
eighty thousand pounds worth of business
rate now we were aware of this we were
certainly aware that there was something
coming so we raise this through
something called the appeals provision
but what we won't know is exactly how
much or or what that was going to be so
we took an estimate what that would be
around three hundred and eighteen
thousand pound so unfortunately there is
a shortfall and that shortfall has to be
fair
through the through the precepts and
authority so for ourselves from Essex
County Council Essex fire and Essex
police part of that is that Rockford has
to take the 40% hit on that number which
would mean for us would be the shortfall
would be around thirty five thousand
pounds
now thirty five thousand pounds will
come straight from our general balance
our general reserve now the good news is
our general reserve at the month is
fairly healthy so that thirty five
thousand ones make a huge dent in it
clearly it's not it's not great but it's
it's at least something we can we can
absorb relatively easily he says and
what I'm more concerned about is
obviously that that's only four of the
purpose-built doctor surgeries there are
another seven out there which have still
yet to have their rateable value
confirmed whether their case will be
approved or not that could be if we use
the same logic that was used on the
first four it could be a further impact
of about three hundred and ninety
thousand pounds again forty percent of
that would be about one hundred and
fifty six thousand pound hit for
Rockford we can move that into next
year's or sorry into funding from our
general balance again this year so we've
got a provision ready for it and as
you'll note in table three point five
we've actually got a fairly healthy
general balance at the moment and it's
got slightly healthier because we have a
tan under spend or so far with forecast
and then under spend for 2016-17 which
will more than absorb this this
provision so the budget for 2017-18 is
still secure and financially we're still
in a in a good shape compared to where
we were previously it's the fact that
basically the under spend from last year
is going to fund this appeals shortfall
so take any questions thank you very
much
councillor Black Sea
q German yeah obviously it's concerning
and the impact on us I've got a couple
of questions first of all I've always
thought released in 2006 2010 but in the
past and NDR was collected by districts
and then sent on to central government
how come we end up footing the bill to
this that's my first question
okay secondly although the report Cygnus
provides details of the appeal
he doesn't really explain personnel
behind it okay and I was wondering if a
principle is established for purpose
block doctor surface does it apply to
other premises like purpose-built
Dental Surgeons or purpose-built school
private schools or anything like that or
purpose built hospitals I mean for one
thing we talked to the previous license
about the proposed changes in the NHS
and I am totally opposed to any
downgrading of the AME itself and so I
suppose if any money goes to certain
aspects with anyway I'll be grateful
what is the risk that the hospitals or
other buildings like that also will have
their weights reduced and ending up in
AMD are reduced greatly thank you thank
you yes yes of coffee
thank you can spec so the the first
question was and it was yes so so in
2010 that's correct sorry so N and D are
in 2010 we did collect fully and we go
back to government and then we got it
back through something called the RSG
revenue support grant in 2011 I believe
that changed so they gave us the power
was to say you can collect business
rates and you can keep it but therefore
you now take the risk entirely on the
appeals provision so that was part of
the part of the funding review that was
done in 2011 2012 I believe
unfortunately that's the situation we're
in we don't have a choice with that if
we quickly know the prospect of in the
future of a hundred seven business rates
they have talked about maybe taking a
provision back into central government
because I mean let's be honest the
impact we've had 35,000 potentially
another 150,000 is fairly minor I know
the appeals provision at Lund
embezzlement counter is around 8 to 9
million so we've got to you know we'll
put this into context we are with
touchwood been fairly like lightly
touched on this so but it is something
we are constantly keeping an eye on you
know business rates for me other is one
of the single biggest risks we had since
your second question what actually
changed was and I won't go into reading
into the detail but basically the the
original valuation was based upon the
rental value so that was as if that that
that dr. surgery wasn't a doctor surgery
in effect it was a house or a home a
unit or whatever space and that could be
rented for X that would be the rateable
value what they successfully appealed
against and said well we would never
rent them out we are purpose-built
doctor surgeries we are not homes or
houses or anything else or businesses so
therefore we should only pay the basic
construction costs the replacement cost
which is in this case around fifty
percent reduction that's the major
change your third part yes there are is
a huge risk around NHS all NHS provision
at the moment is going as high as it can
possibly go in the country because many
of the NHS trusts are raising appeals
against their business rates so if you
stand back and look at this from a from
a resident of the country it doesn't
really matter does it it's robbing Peter
to pay Paul if they don't give us the
money then it goes to the NHS it's still
only the money sloshing around the
system so we are hoping that the
government are going to be quite
sensible about this and actually stop
any further provision certainly on the
bigger things but it's certainly a risk
and there's a lot of work going on in
the background at the moment I think
there's lawyers involved from the whole
of the Local Government Association and
looking at this so it it's a it's a big
issue yes thank you very much any other
critics sorry sorry time I just like to
reiterate to members that the reason why
we're in this situation
is not because any sort of mistake or
misjudgment has happened in right Road
these are factors way beyond our control
and essentially we have just been
passages on this ride I will say through
through through good management of our
finances by rather than through
bye Deniz murugu and we are in a
position to absorb this one unpalatable
as it is however it is a bit of a worry
where the future might go but we are
hoping that common sense will prevail
ultimately thanks miscounted John may
simply say no and I'm very grateful to
councillor black having raised that
potential and mr. Manning to have
considered it that it's worried me now
because I just wonder how big that risk
is for us from the NHS in lots of
districts I think of parts of rotted
Hospital that still are through
operating and I presume that hospital
was purpose-built in its time a long
long time ago and is that the sort of
building that we would be at risk for
reclaim of business straits
fucknuts and before I go I just like to
agree completely we've counted a black
who used a very good opportunity to say
and I will say - I'm totally against the
south end A&E not becoming a walking and
not a fully functional A&E as well thank
you thank you - and so yes council Mason
at the moment my understanding is the
oxford hospital won't be impacted by
this decision or certainly hasn't been
in terms of the scope of the other trust
that put themselves forward certainly in
terms of the type of building and the
type of property however I'm not going
to say that not forever so at the moment
we're keeping much more of a watching
brief on it rather than raising a
specific provision but I'll be honest
this is discussed certainly every month
at the ear for 8006 finance Officers
Association it's right up there on our
top agenda at the moment we are
certainly I don't see us being impacted
immediately but as soon as we start to
see the similar types of properties that
Rochford has then we would start to
raise this as an issue yes
members the recommendation on 15.3 it is
proposed to the capsule resolve one into
that agreed members alright number
sixteen members of the public we have
come to the end of the business that we
can debate with you present the
remaining report contains exempt
information and I would therefore ask
that you now leave the meeting point of
order to thank Karen on with regard to
my team I believe this could be heard in
public and is in the public interest to
be third I think if we heard with remove
you've just earned a very few items from
the report and I would not agree to the
exclusion on that basis we can do 18
first if you prefer members no chair
move on am the report itself does
contain
financial information and from
contractors and is my advice that issue
remain exempt right its council hi so as
I pointed out there are some what is
within it however the report is one of
these reports where I think I think the
mannequin daughter did email round whose
accounts are saying that this would be
sorted out this report can be heard in
public would removal of certain ISIL I
think the report has been prepared with
those items in it so I can't be heard in
public and ease in my view in the public
interest
[Music]
which case
okay members
I'll see what we've got to do is because
on puzzle paper we were to take a vote
and to see whether the the item is going
to be fun and confidential yes counselor
swearing thank you Jim
councillor boys just said that an email
when bound upon to check with my
colleagues none of us have seen an email
about anything
yes confirmation yes Jen and the the
managing director in November and I
didn't actually remember the date that
he can only sit today so he knows what
I'm talking about sending the email all
members in which he set out a particular
instructions offices and the destruction
to officers was to was to consider
exempt reports and and in a practical
sense to to determine that there were
parts and it would be rare if they
couldn't be be heard in public but there
should be an exempt appendix and council
the holy is properly applying to this
debate five by reminding members that
they all received that email and the
issue tonight is not about whether this
particular report has the same exempt
but the fact that his instructions and
have not been properly carried out
officers have been have been quite
properly instructed to consider all
exempt reports to consider them with the
monitoring officer within particular to
consider whether part of them can be can
be heard in public and the exempt parts
tilt avoid putting an appendix and
therefore what we have here tonight is a
situation where we're not serving
democracy we're not serving transparency
at all we've put four items in to exempt
when frankly that's that's our almost
unprecedented managing director agrees
with me today it is unprecedented but
what's even more unprecedented is that
of these reports including item 18 there
are implications and those implications
should be made known to the public at
the very least and at the moment and as
they currents continues they will be
completely unaware of what is going on
in this council and that is totally
unacceptable to me totally Thank You
counsel amazing accounts especially
chairman and I'm not going to say
whether I agree the council nations
points or not buddy
I believe he's opening up a debate which
is not for the here and now what we have
before us is an agenda on the agenda is
an item that's on purple paper we have
had specific advice from our legal
officer that they believe that it should
remain in P&C
and I think we need to have the vote if
that's the way you feel it's appropriate
to determine whether we keep it in in P
and C I don't I don't believe that the
debate should be opened up to things
outside the agenda at this moment in
time thank you
I think of council Black Sea share
councillor Mason has the hoist concerns
about the item 18 I'm also looking at
another light of me and I won't cease
when it is it it is another exempt
appendix where it refers in there it
with Thurston fact that members wanted
to whisk this on to be recorded I'm
having it recorded and this between see
especially means it's not believe it'll
be nobody's ever going to see it and I
don't and I don't see and it's on page
one of our exempt appendix and it's
preferred paragraph down for a bullet
point down and I don't see why that is
in exempt because its members doing
their job on review committee and
feeling frustrated of the review
committee that of course has not been
answered and I think that should not
being accept and I'll query why it's
exempt I think it's awfully convenient
but it's exempt
I'm causa black cancer mounting please
thank you count from our counselor
Wilson please thank you madam chair I
asked how items become an exempt is
there a mechanism for doing this is
there a mechanism for reviewing it
there's my experience I've worked in
central government and what happens is
after a certain period information is
reviewed and where necessary downgraded
and it doesn't seem to be a mechanism
for this to happen in our council I I
think at the moment with reservation on
something that is on purple papers and I
think really I think we're going to take
a vote on it sorry members but I've
otherwise will go on life debating on
okay Sherman
reports that I've been determined is
exempt by the monitoring officer if
there's a point when the items within
the report are no longer confidential or
legal privilege or whatever the reasons
those reports can be made publicly
available and some councils at times do
do that or officers conclude that
definitely they eat they don't stay
exempt necessarily but at this point in
time the reports before members that are
on purple paper are very much covering
areas that are potentially something
that is best for the council SEC tape
kept in the council domain however as
the chairman suggesting there could be a
vote on whether item 18 in terms of
discussion that discussions public or
private the only possibility is that it
is about avoiding discussion that might
bring out something that for the council
and residents Ike is best at this point
not you know moment kept confidential
the only other aspect is that the the
minute from any meeting light like this
meeting should give a real flavour and
an indication of what the item was about
Gemma nuts one more council Braxley
I hear what mr. boss thought says I
wonder if you could look at the the
purple paper regarding exempt appendix
on the review committee so you explained
to me I don't see why that third have
that third bullet point should be in
comprised of confidential the one that
begins members wished it to be recorded
or so I'm after that so I'm looking at
the is being sent um exempt item number
what's important okay
members please are we talking about item
18 here that the exempt appendix put in
your view committee review committee the
fourth of April this year which which
paper are you looking at I can't see
your number on it it's not at the red
bottom
these things about I'll never had an 18
and I'm asking why why this is procedure
to German the documents that counselor
black has is is an exempt appendix is
actually the appendix to the view
committees minutes which do form part of
the report that is exempt item 17 that's
before members tonight
sure perhaps counsel black could clarify
the third bullet points yeah okay
members we're going to take a vote on
whether sorry counsel mr. nice and quick
one please some 17 these are activities
we've got action I rewrote it but I
think the point of concern that tells
the black you say that it's a copy of
the expense of paydex it's set to 1.1
1.2 and 1.3 is that correct
so why that's additional bit as in Wiley
managing directors instructions I'm
going to pull it out we've caused all
this confusion today so hopefully that
we rectified in future Thank You counsel
may heaven clean members we're going to
take a vote on item 18 whether it's PNC
or or not
can we write item 18 to and to agree of
PNC in this council for the eighth to
leave the chamber is can I have the your
agreement to yes is it permanent
confidential German I'm sorry but I'm
not clear on what voting here face
purple paper item 18 is it PNC in this
chamber this evening which means members
of the public have to leave so yeah for
the purple paper up in PNC so those in
favor at being PNC can you please
indicate
and against members please like folks
games to be recorded in a minute I know
today's lost members and your vote will
be recorded okay hey stop the folks have
been taken we've got members who wanted
voted to be acknowledged and therefore
can the members of the public please
leave the chamber
which 18 against 19
you know I keep rolling against it and
direct question that because as far as I
was aware with the unwary 19 for PNC and
18 against PMP formative protecting I
believe shall we take the first again
member shall we say just the counterpane
for their purple pay for the VPN okay
you will be using the customs
automatically people in claim
so it looks like in a recorded vote now
members right we're voting the purple
paper item 18 to be PNC so the member
the public has to leave if it's not
being see then they can come back in
again but they've probably gone home now
council Carter counselor mrs. Ford are
helpful a Koopa now to the drain
counselor SC
counselor
councilor Griffin councillor Hazelwood
council to hook way
councillor Diane boy comes for the
michael voice counsel is a few helpful
you are know how a little field helping
this is army more helpful equipping
later ok cancer alias make Chancellor
John Mason
counselor merit for counsel mill or
counselor mountain okay
capsule an earful
counselor awesome oh you counselor mrs.
Rowe counselor mrs. Shaw counselor Smith
or counter the fairing for counselors
family counselor Seto or capital award
or counselor web or counselor mrs.
Webster for counselor William counselor
Wilson
it's equal 18 18 so I'm afraid I'm gonna
have to use my casting vote I'm by going
by the legal team and decrees on purple
paper
I'm afraid on four so purple paper is
PNC